si hay que resaltar que yo vayan dijo
que hay un interés genuino en
restablecer las relaciones bilaterales
sin ceder en los valores de eeuu en este
sentido dijo que pues era impresentable
que un país que defiende la libertad y
los derechos humanos no trajera colación
en esta cumbre el tema de alexéi navalni
payden dijo que era ridículo además que
el presidente vladimir putin haya
comparado el caso del 6 de enero con lo
con el tema de alexéi navalni y pues
mencionó también que en el caso de los
ataques cibernéticos habrá consecuencias
ahora acciones por parte de eeuu si no
se hace nada al respecto y en varias
ocasiones en este discurso que fue más
breve que el de vladimir putin pues el
joven le preguntó a la audiencia le
resaltó al presidente vladimir putin que
pues qué pasaría si rusia fuera atacada
en su sistema de energía en su sistema
hospitalario en sus elecciones o en las
agencias de gobierno como ha sido
víctima eeuu recientemente y se lo
mencionaba no en un tono de amenaza sino
en tono un reflexión en un tono de traer
a la mesa esto para poder llegar a un
acuerdo no dijo que no le preocupa el
tema de que el rusia ve a un
escalamiento en esta relación como un
tema de guerra fría que eso no era
preocupación para vladimir putin sin
embargo y hizo algo dijo algo que llamó
la atención y es el tema de la frontera
la gran frontera que comparte rusia con
china volvió a traer yo bailé en el tema
de china a la mesa es un tema que trató
en los días previos en la cumbre aun la
otan y en su reunión con los países del
g7 china fue uno de los temas
principales el crecimiento de china xi
representa una amenaza o si es un socio
estratégico para los países para los
países europeos y para eeuu cuál va a
ser la posición conjunta del g7 y de la
otan con respecto a china no tanto con
respecto a estados conflictos
bilaterales que se están dando así que
el hecho de que yo vaya
el tema de china a colación sobre todo
teniendo en cuenta la gran frontera que
comparte rusia y china- es un tema
importante le dijo ahora en el putting
que tenía que tener una política más
activa con respecto a china teniendo en
cuenta pues la gran influencia que está
teniendo este país no solamente a nivel
pues económico sino a nivel geopolítico
a través de todos los préstamos y la
ayuda generan temas de grandes proyectos
de infraestructura a asia áfrica y
américa latina por último resaltar
también el tema de la libertad de prensa
lo último le cedió la palabra a
periodistas rusos diciendo que el tema
la libertad de prensa final que termina
dijo bailén afectando esa vladimir putin
porque entre más limité a los
periodistas no solamente en rusia sino
también en ucrania pues va a terminar
limitando iba a terminar afectando la
credibilidad de vladimir putin en este
sentido en temas de credibilidad también
le dijo que no era un tema de amenazas
que no era un tema de pues tratar de
empezar pelea sino que no solamente con
el tema de la libertad de prensa sino
también con
la falta de respeto a los derechos
humanos vladimir putin eran más
afectados precisamente por esto por
perder credibilidad cristóbal retomamos
un poco los acuerdos o los compromisos
que se acordaron durante esta jornada
hay algún plazo ya se habla de algún
plazo para cumplirlos
pues recordemos que acordaron que iban a
volver a enviar embajadores a moscú y
washington respectivamente hace varios
meses la residencia del embajador ruso
aquí en la capital muy cerca a la casa
blanca pues ha estado vacía ha estado
con las cortinas cerradas no se sabe
todavía el plazo concreto cuando
enviaran otra vez nuevamente embajadores
recordemos que aunque no están los
embajadores hay todo un cuerpo
diplomático ruso acá en washington y en
varias ciudades principales aunque no
estén los cónsules tampoco en algunas
ciudades precisamente por la retaliación
que tomo eeuu después de que se dijera
por parte de organismos de inteligencia
que en eeuu que los ciberataques habían
sido de rusia habían sido de agencias de
inteligencia rusas que estaban detrás
posiblemente de estos ciberataques se
habló también de volver a un diálogo
constructivo sobre precisamente este
tema de los ciberataques y en repetidas
ocasiones yo vaivén pues dijo en esta
rueda de prensa que había que esperar a
ver sí
todas estas promesas todo lo que se
había hablado en esta cumbre que duró
cerca de tres horas 21 minutos entre los
dos mandatarios pues se iba a traducir
en acciones varias veces dijo joe biden
que eran muy buenas las intenciones que
se había hablado en un tono pacífico en
un tono constructivo positivo pero que
era por esperarse que ésta por esperarse
sin rusia y si vladimir putin y su
gobierno hacen algo con respecto a los
ataques cibernéticos que recordemos
varias veces las agencias de
inteligencia acá en este país han dicho
que son los rusos son varios grupos de
hackers rusos los que estuvieron detrás
de la interferencia en el tema de
elecciones e interferencia en pues el
tema hospitalario y el tema energético
recientemente con colonial pipeline